this is the standard form of a complex
number a + bi this is the real part and
this is the imaginary part and then this
is the trigonometric form of a complex
number sometimes it's written as our sis
theta like that the C is the cosign I
sign it so it's like an abbreviation but
R is considered the modulus of Z it's
the distance from the origin to the
point as it's graphed in the complex
plane and then theta is the argument
which is the angle that the complex
number makes with the horizontal the
positive x-axis the horizontal and if
you want to switch from the
trigonometric form back into the
standard form all you have to do is
distribute our okay so you get R cosine
theta that's going to give you the real
portion and distribute the R that's
going to give you R sine theta that's
the imaginary portion and that's how you
can switch back and forth between the
two forms okay so then if they give it
to you in this form okay like this you
can take a squared plus b squared and
take the square root that'll give you R
and then if you want to find the angle
you do the tangent inverse of B over a
to get the theta so let's look at a
couple examples so say we want to write
3 plus 4i in that trigonometric form
okay I'll just draw a quick diagram here
so this is one two three one two three
four okay so there's three plus 4i
plotted in the complex plane like the
real and the imaginary plane here and
what we're doing is we're finding this
distance okay from here the origin to
this point and so what you can do is you
can do the Pythagorean theorem or you
can use this formula here square root of
a squared plus B squared so this is
going to be nine plus sixteen take the
square root
that gives us five okay now to find this
angle theta okay what we can do is we
can use tangent inverse of B over a so
theta equals the tangent inverse of B
which is four over three so
let's do that in the calculator and see
what that comes out to tangent inverse
of 4/3 which is fifty three point one
okay so we've got fifty three point one
degrees so if we're going to write this
in trigonometric form we've got five
cosine fifty three point one plus I sine
fifty three point one and there's your
trigonometric form so we found this R
value okay which is like the distance
from the origin to the point in the
complex plane there and then we found
the angle that it makes here with the
positive x-axis okay now we're going to
go from the trigonometric form to
standard form so how do we do that
what we're going to do is we're going to
think about distributing this R value to
the cosine and the sine so that's going
to give us ten cosine PI over three plus
10i sine PI over three PI over 3 cosine
PI over three is 1/2 times ten will give
you five sine PI over three is square
root 3 over 2 so that's going to give
you let's see so ten times square root
of 3 over 2i but the 2 and the 10 you
can see reduce so that's going to give
you five plus five square root of 3i so
now we're back into the standard form it